the highly anticipated movie a wrinkle
in time is based on the best-selling
1962 novel of the very same name the
movies directed by the great Ava
Duvernay and she's a big Award winner
who's best known for Selma and Queen
sugar the story follows a teenager named
Meg who travels through time to rescue
her missing father along the way she's
helped by three supernatural beings
called the mrs. Reese Witherspoon
portrays mrs. whatsit mindy kaling plays
mrs. who and oprah winfrey portrays the
wisest mrs. which it was a preview well
no don't come over there
you just have to find the right
frequency and have faith in who you are
[Music]
let's find your father shall we
find your father Oprah is this you who
is your character tell me about missus
which is a combination for me of Glinda
the Good Witch in The Wizard of Oz which
is my favorite movie of all times and
actually one of my favorite spiritual
enlightenment teachings when Glinda says
you've always had it always had the
power so I you know the the very idea of
being able to portray one of the wisest
woman women in the millennia way
exciting was not a stretch felt right
okay yeah I know because I have been
counseled by some of the wisest Maya
Angelou so she felt like a combination
this character mrs. which felt like a
combination of Maya I could hear Maya in
my head the whole time every time I
spoke and of Glinda
mm-hm we've always had it my dear Glinda
the Good Witch and there are many lines
that my character misses which says like
all you have to do is find the right
frequency and have faith in who you are
those are not my exact words but many
many times when I'm counseling my own
girls in you know from my school in
South ever I'll say you gotta find your
flow I mean it's a way of speaking to
them about being who you are finding
your flow staying in your lane not
worrying about what the other person is
doing so when mrs. which says just
finding your frequency and having faith
in who you are that's kind of coming
from her but you say the star the movie
is storm read who I hear is described as
gold and she is golden so let me say
this would be like you know I'm out
promoting this movie because first of
all I believe in Ava Duvernay and wanted
to support her to the highest degree but
it's not my movie
it's storms movie it's Derrick McCabe's
movie who plays a little boy
it's Levi's movie and it's a story of
this young girl who's searching for her
father out in the cosmos and in the
search discovers herself so it's a
wonderful children's movie and even
described it as family fantastical movie
I like that too okay it and I thought I
want you to know that that that it's it
would be like that it's not yours not
mine could be like Glinda the Good Witch
you know talking about the eyes
I was I was obsessed with your eyebrows
I have to say but I was mostly obsessed
with Meg yeah and what story what a
character and and empowering and and
obviously the timing is tragic for young
Lindsay dental but when you see the
students in parkland and you see the
power that they have and I watched this
movie on Friday and you see the power
and confidence that these children have
you can't help but be walking away
feeling confident about children really
I'm preaching leaders and I'm
particularly excited about children
everywhere and it's been pointed out to
me that there were children marching in
Ferguson and children marching in
Chicago and now children marching in
Parkland I believe the children are the
future I believe that just like the
civil rights movement it was the young
people who said we've had enough it was
the young people who said we are not
going to tolerate what our parents have
tolerated for years and I believe that
we're on the verge of something really
really big happening it does feel
different in fact you gave $500,000 to
that yes I did because you want to make
sure that the kids who want to get there
can get there that's right for kids who
want to come from all around the country
who want to be able to get there and
can't afford to get there are you
planning to be at the March I'm not
planning to be at things because I think
about the children not about you know I
want to go back to the movie about the
children because this is what people are
saying about the great Ava
Elaine Walter Walter Roth who is a
former Teen Vogue editor said if you had
told me as a little girl that I would be
standing in the presence of absolute
greatness to bear witness to a little
brown girl with big curly hair saving
the world on the big screen I might have
known my own magic sooner Bernie Bell
says Thank You Ava for taking us on a
dreamy ride and adventure with a little
brown girl
Ava's called to cast the movie this yes
it was her call to put a little brown
girl at the center of it storm read and
also to diversify the mrs. because when
you those of you who grew up with the
book the mrs. don't look like me or look
like Mindy or even Reese for that matter
so I think you know Ava's whole work on
the planet is about inclusion and about
yours too and my
- I love you in Ava together because you
guys are a great one-two punch yeah it's
really gonna play off of each other
really what people do we don't want
people to mistake this is a story about
adolescence but it's also that's a more
universal message this idea of finding
your own voice and your own path it's
not just for that's why the book has
such wide appeal yes and it's not just
well well that's why it's a fantastical
book for children families young girls
is because it's about discovering your
own voice at the age where you're trying
to figure out is it my voice or should I
do what everybody else wants me to do
and overcoming insecurities as well what
if any insecurities have you had it I've
had a lot to overcome but I think the
the most important essential thing to
understand about all of us that the
thread that runs through all of us is
what meg says at the end of the movie I
deserve to be loved
remember in that what she said I deserve
to be loved and I think people are they
suffer in direct proportion to how they
don't believe that they deserve to be
loved and so it all comes back to how
loved are you and do you believe that
you're worthy of being loved which goes
back to what you were saying about the
schools yes kids who don't who need yeah
and if you've been traumatized if you've
been traumatized you can't you can't
feel that you can't get to those
feelings yes thank you all oh oh all
right so let me ask you about this call
for you to run for president let me
leave it up though you already said no
that it's gotten your DNA but I'm
interested in the notion of when you
hear the call about whatever you do is
what how do you know now is the time for
me to step in and step up because it's
something you will feel now I will tell
you all that I was actually I was in my
gym in Maui preparing rehearsing the
speech and that's where you first heard
the speech Jim in Maui yeah and Gail
comes in and I say I want you to hear
something I wanted to hear this speech
that I was doing at the Golden Globes
and Gail goes look I just wanted to talk
to you about something I know if I say
it like that you say it's not going to
be good for you
but I did say I think it would be good
for the country and I'm like get out of
here okay I'd wanted you
listen to the speech so I believe that
for everything that anybody does there
is a feeling not just voices outside
yourself telling you to do something but
there's a feeling that you have about
yes this is direction I should move in
is that feeling grace some people call
that grace grace gives you the ability
to see or is it I think it is an it is
an instinct is it is an intuition it is
a need I call it your internal guidance
and system your own personal GPS that
says this is the way and so and I also
think Oprah nobody should be convinced
to run to run for the presidency but I
also think you have a very unique
ability in terms of healing and
connecting all people and I have the
great compassion for people I know that
I think I know that more than compassion
to be the president of you what do you
think Maya would say it's one of these
times I really wish Maya was here what
do you think that she would say
certainly out she'd say baby listen to
your own heart
I read somebody said that if you ran the
day you decided to run half the country
would hate you immediately that is true
not helping no even Gayle said when she
comes in to try to convince me that I
should run for president says look it's
not gonna be good for you she goes it's
not even gonna be good for me yes
somebody told me you'd have to leave
your job at CBS I go why do I have to
leave my job at CBS I think you might
know no I don't thank you thanks for all
the same to me maybe you need to rethink
yeah I thought the I was pushing about
you being insecure was interesting
because I've never I know I didn't have
the question I just you did well it
never shows we gotta go okay yes
well the wrinkle in time go see it it
opens nationwide on Friday it's a
fantastic movie